♪ (intro music) ♪
It's really just in all of --
what machine learning is capable of,
in how we can extend human capabilities.
And we want to think more than just
about discovering new approaches
and new ways of using technology;
we want to see how it's being used
and how it impacts
the human creative process.
So imagine, you need to find
or compose a drum pattern,
and you have some idea of a drum beat
that you would like to compose,
and all you need to do now
is go to a website
where there's a pre-trained model
of drum patterns
sitting on the online--
you just need a web browser.
You give it some human input and you can
generate a space of expressive variations.
You can tune and control
the type of outputs
that you're getting
from this generative model.
And if you don't like it,
you can continue going through it
exploring this generative space.
So this is the type of work
that Project Magenta focuses on.
To give you a bird's eye view
of what Project Magenta is about,
it basically is a group of researchers,
and developers and creative technologists
that engage in generative models research.
So you'll see this work published
in machine learning conferences,
you'll see the workshops,
you'll see a lot of research contributions
from Magenta.
You'll also see the code
that after it's been published
put into open source repository
on GitHub in the Magenta repo.
And then from there we'll see ways
of thinking and designing creative tools
that can enhance and extend the human
expressive creative process.
And eventually, ending up into the hands
of artists and musicians
inventing new ways we can create
and inventing new types of artists.
So, I'm going to give three brief
overviews of the highlights
of some of our recent work.
So this is PerformanceRNN.
How many people have seen this?
This is one of the demos earlier today.
A lot of people have seen
and heard of this kind of work,
and this is what people typically think
of when they're thinking
of a generative model, they're thinking,
"How can we build a computer
that has the kind of intuition
to know the qualities
of things like melody and harmony,
but also expressive timing and dynamics?"
And what's even more--
it's even more interesting now
to be able to explore this for yourself
in the browser enabled by TensorFlow.js.
So,this is a demo we have running online.
We have the ability to tune and control
some of the output that we're getting.
So in a second, I'm going to show you
this video of what that looks like,
you would have seen
it out on the demo floor
but we will show you
and all of you watching online,
and we were also able to bring it
even more alive by connecting
a baby grand piano Disklavier
that is also a midi controller
and we have the ability to perform
alongside the generative model
reading in the inputs
from the human playing the piano.
So, let's take a look.
♪ (piano) ♪
So this is trained on classical music
data from actual live performers.
This is from a data set that we got,
from a piano competition.
♪ (piano) ♪
I don't know if you noticed,
this is Nikhil from earlier today.
He's actually quite a talented young man.
He helped build out the browser version
of PerformanceRNN.
♪ (piano) ♪
And so we're thinking of ways
that we take bodies of work,
we train a model off of the data,
then we create these open source tools
that enable new forms of interaction
of creativity and of expression.
And this is all these points of engagement
are enabled by TensorFlow.
The next tool I want to talk about
that we've been working on
is Variational Autoencoders.
How many people are familiar
Layton's space interpolation?
Okay, quite a few of you.
And if you're not, it's quite simple--
you take human inputs
and you train it through
on your own network,
compressing it down to an embedding space.
So you compress it down
to some dimensionality
and then you reconstruct it.
So you're comparing the reconstruction
with the original and trying to train,
build a space around that,
and what that does is that creates
the ability to interpolate
from one point to another
touching on the intermediate points
where a human may have not given input.
So the machine learning model
may have never seen an example
that it's able to generate,
because it's building an intuition
off of these examples.
So, you can imagine if you're an animator,
there's so many ways
of going from cat to pig.
How would you animate that?
So, we're train--there's an intuition
that the artist would have
in creating that sort of morphing
from one to the other.
So we're able to have the machine learning
model now also do this.
We can also do this with sound, right?
This technology actually carries
over to multiple domains.
So, this is NSynth,
and we've released this,
I think some time last year.
And what it does is
it takes that same idea
of moving one input to another.
So, let's take a look.
You'll get a sense of it.
Piccolo to electric guitar.
(electric guitar sound to piccolo)
(piccolo sound to electric guitar)
(piccolo and electric guitar
sound together)
So, rather than recomposing
or fading from one sound to the other,
what we're actually able to do
is we're able to find these intermediary,
recomposed sound samples
and produce that.
So, it looks, you know,
there's a lot of components to that.
There's a wave and a decoder,
but really it's the same technology
underlying the encoder-decoder
variational autoencoder.
But when we think about the types
of tools that musicians use,
we think less about training
machine learning models.
We see drum pedals right? --
I mean not drum pedals.
Guitar pedals, these knobs
and these pedals
that are used to tune and refine sound
to cultivate the kind of art
and flavor a musician is looking for.
We don't think so much
about setting parameter flags
or trying to write lines of python code
to create this sort of art in general.
So what we've done--
Not just are we interested
in finding and discovering new things.
We're also interested in how those things
get used in general--
used by practitioners,
used by specialists.
And so we've created hardware,
we've taken a piece of hardware
where we've taken the machine learning
model, we've put it into a box
where a musician can just plug in
and explore this latent space
in performance.
So take a look on how musicians feel,
what they think in this process.
♪ (music) ♪
(woman) I just feel like
we're turning a corner
of what could be new possibility.
It could generate a sound
that might inspire us.
(man) The fun part is even though
you think you know what you're doing,
there's some weird interaction happening
that can give you something
totally unexpected.
I mean, it's great research,
and it's really fun,
and it's amazing to discover new things,
but it's even more amazing to see
how it gets used and what people
think to create with alongside it.
And so, what's even better
is that it's just released, NSynth Super,
in collaboration
with the Creative Lab London.
It's an open source hardware project.
All the information
and the specs are on GitHub.
We talk about everything
from potentiometers,
to the touch panel, to the code
and what hardware it's running on.
And this is all available
to everyone here today.
You just go online
and you can check it out yourself.
Now music is more than just sound right?
It's actually a sequence
of things that goes on.
So when we think about this idea
of what it means
to have a generative music space,
we think also about melodies,
and so just like we have cat to pig,
what is it like to go
from one melody to the next?
And moreover, once we have
that technology, how does it --
what does it look like
to create with that?
You have this expressive space
of variations--
how do we design an expressive tool
that takes advantage of that?
And what will we get out of it?
So this is also another tool
that's developed
by another team at Google,
to make use of melodies in a latent space,
so how interpolation works,
and then building a song
or some sort of composition with it.
So let's take a listen.
Say you have two melodies....
♪ ("Twinkle Twinkle Little Star") ♪
And in the middle....
♪ (piano playing variation) ♪
You can extend it....
And we really are just scratching
the surface of what's possible.
How do we continue
to have the machine learn
and have a better intuition
for what melodies are about.
So again to bring it back full circle,
using different compositions
and musical works, we're able to train
a variational autoencoder
to create an embedding space
that builds tools that enable
open source communities
to design creative artist's tools
to look at new ways of pushing
the expressive boundaries
that we currently have.
This is, again, just released!
It's on our blog.
All the code is an open source
and made available to you,
and also enabled by TensorFlow.
In addition to all these other things,
including Nikhil,
here, enabled by the type of work
and creativity and expressivity.
And so, in wrapping up
I want to take us back
to this demo that we saw.
Now the most interesting and maybe
the coolest thing about this demo,
was that we didn't even know
that it was being built
until it was tweeted by Tero,
a developer from Finland.
And the fact of the matter is that
we're just barely scratching the surface.
There's so much to do,
so much to engage in,
and so much to discover.
And we want to see so much more of this.
We want to see more developers,
more people sharing things
and more people getting engaged.
Not just developers,
but artists and creatives as well.
We want to explore and invent
and imagine what we can do
with machine learning together
as an expressive tool.
And so, go to our website,
g.co/magenta.
There you'll find our publications
and these demos,
you can experience it yourself, and more.
And you can also join
our discussion group.
So here's g.co/magenta.
Join our discussion group,
become part of the community,
and share the things that you're building,
so we can do this alongside together.
Thank you so much.
(applause)
So that's it for the talks today.
We had an amazing, amazing show,
amazing spread of speakers and topics.
Now, let's take a look at
a highlight review of the day.
♪ (music) ♪
Earlier this year we hit the milestone
of 11 million downloads.
We really excited to see how much users
are using this and how much impact
it's having in the world.
We're very excited today
to announce that deeplearn.js
is joining the TensorFlow family.
♪ (music) ♪
(man) The software TensorFlow,
is also an early-stage project.
And so we'd really love for you
to get interested
and help us to build this future.
♪ (music) ♪
(man) I told you at the beginning
that our mission for TF data
was to make a live [inaudible] processing
that is fast, flexible and easy to use.
♪ (music) ♪
(woman) I'm very excited to say
that we have been working
with other teams in Google
to bring TensorFlow Lite to Google Labs.
♪ (music) ♪
(man) In general the Google
Brain Team's mission
is to make machines intelligent,
and then use that ability
to improve people's lives.
I think these are good examples of where
there's real opportunity for this.
♪ (music ends) ♪
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪